et ouais ouais ça lui sert ce grand
public quelque chose comme 22h03 le
tabloïd avait lieu d'ici la conférence
du tableau d'ici la conférence
d'ouverture vient à peine de se terminer
et quelle surprise que du software pas
de hardware pas un seul mot sur un
iphone sf2 sur un ipad feront sur un
macbook
rien que tu chies walou nada tim cook et
toute son équipe pour présenter les
nouveaux os
les mises à jour les nouveautés
passionnant passionnante
je vous rassure mais pas du tout du
hardware dont je fais la fois content et
à la mode issue
bon allez on y va on en parle
le tabloïd a fallu dix sites attendue
avec beaucoup d'intérêt vraiment on
attendait beaucoup de produits j'étais
le premier à espérer l'arrivée d'un
iphone s2 pour me remplacer l'iphone est
ce qui a quand même quelques petites
années maintenant un ipad pro ça
m'aurait semblé logique n'avait pas trop
aride à ce moment là il n'y avait pas d'
qui a été annoncé il ya pas très
longtemps l'ipad 9,7 pouces
j'attends également des macbook pro et
tout ça que dalle donc je pense qu'il va
falloir attendre le mois de septembre
la keynote de présentation du hardware
pont coûterait clairement là on va
vraiment la stratégie d'apple qui se
décide c'est à dire il ya un produit qui
était en soi un événement spécial c'est
cet ipad 9,7 pouces là un événement
uniquement développeurs uniquement
logiciel vraiment creusot n'est pour une
fois pas du tout de matériel et on va
arriver ensuite sur la keynote du mode
septembre qui est vraiment à la
présentation matérielle ou après coup il
y aura pas logiciel néanmoins je vous
rassure il ya eu plein de choses hyper
intéressante
on a passé plus de deux heures à écouter
cette keynote du tabloïd bild ici j'ai
pris plein note en faire un résumé pour
avoir une vue globale une vue d'ensemble
des nouveautés alors déjà on commence
avec ios 12
eyeos on a vraiment présenté son lot
d'innovations eyeos 12 d'apporter
quelques nouveautés sens bien
révolutionner l'histoire le cac continue
à être donnée vers la réalité augmentée
on l'a déjà vu l'année dernière avec un
os 11
c'est confirmé cette fois-ci caillou s12
tim cook et toute son équipe a vraiment
miser davantage par la réalité augmentée
tout à la réalité virtuelle
il l'avait déjà dit considère que la
réalité augmentée beaucoup plus d'avenir
parce que c'est beaucoup moins en
fermant que la réalité virtuelle et
d'ailleurs on l'a vu lorsque l'on fait
une présentation pour montrer un jeu de
lego physique avec la réalité augmentée
on voit que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui n'enferment pas puisqu'il peut y
avoir du multijoueur et ça c'est
effectivement la nouveauté de la réalité
augmentée sur ios 12/100 l'ouest en
général il doit y avoir deux meilleures
performances
une batterie préserver nos vraiment mis
l'accent sur la batterie ça rappelle un
peu toutes les histoires de vatry
d'obsolescence programmée je mets des
guillemets parce qu'il est absolument
aucune condamnation en appel à cannes
était montrée du doigt et il ya eu pas
mal de plaintes dans différents pays
à ce sujet vous déjà fait des vidéos et
dessus et là pour le coup il met
vraiment en avant la préservation de la
batterie donc
ray volonté d'apple de faire attention
la durée de vie de leurs batteries donc
d'avoir un noël vraiment optimisé la
réalité augmentée avec un tout nouveau
format qui s'appelle l'usb z la rai
d'augmenter on va retrouver donc plus en
plus d'applications une application
mesure qu'on a déjà pu voir chez des
éditeurs tiers
une application qui vous permet de
mesurer un objet de mesurer un cadre de
mesures et une valise sont montrés une
valise potron la dimension d'une valise
on a déjà pour 3 à ce que quelques
applications où on pouvait avec la
reille de vente est mesuré une pièce et
faire le plan en deux dimensions de sa
pièce ou en trois dimensions là ça
illustre vraiment ce qu'on peut faire
avec la réalité augmentée tiré pour nous
rendre service pas uniquement pour du
gel ludique pas uniquement pour faire
apparaître un dinosaure dans une pièce
pareil lorsque vous allez faire du
shopping par exemple montré pour acheter
une guitare une fender vous allez sur
catalogue et vous aide à faire
apparaître dans votre pièce en taille
réelle pour vous rendre compte du volume
ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai déjà
ikea avec son application on peut faire
apparaître ces meubles en réalité
augmentée dans une pièce c'est plutôt
intéressant et d'une nouveauté aussi du
côté de la photo pour de la recherche
lorsque vous allez vouloir un petit peu
navigué dans vos images il va y avoir de
la suggestion de recherche de faire de
la recherche
hop bonne technique vous pouvez faire de
la recherche multi terme par exemple
rechercher un lieu une catégorie on peut
rechercher dans un musée on va
d'ailleurs qu'à une classification qui
se fait au travers d'une intelligence
artificielle pour pouvoir accéder à ces
photos plus rapidement mieux l'étrier
aux racks et une meilleure information
d'ailleurs en photo il ya un nouvel
onglet crie son apparition c'est
l'onglet for you pour vous voilà pour
vous très clémente qui va vous faire des
suggestions de souvenirs des suggestions
des faits qui à vous inciter au partage
à partager vos souvenirs vos photos
directement avec vos amis on va plier
sociale et il y en avant pour vraiment
aller sur le partage et pour donner vie
à toutes ces photos et pas juste les
stocker en banque de souvenirs une mise
à jour de syrie avec les chiottes sert à
quoi nous permettre dans une application
de pouvoir enregistrer interne pour
créer une action alors comme ça ça peut
vous paraître un petit peu sorcier vous
enregistrer un message par exemple en
disant je pars eh bien lorsque vous
dites je parasiris si rien pouvoir faire
des actions complexes c'est à dire
envoyer un message à votre ami votre
copain d'autres copines pour le dire je
pars donc je vais bientôt rentrer à sa
luge sur le départ j'aime est là ça
permet aussi de lancer le chauffage chez
vous pourquoi pas de lancer de la
musique enfin ça pas mal d'applications
que peut être programmé bons coups ce
qui
très intéressant là dessus s'est fait
rendre compte qu'on peut commencer à
personnaliser syrie et a créé des
actions qui vous sont propres et pas
uniquement d'utiliser syrie avec des
modèles de voix avec des actions pré
enregistré l'application news ce rail
pad qui s'offre également un nouveau
design
les mémos vocaux sur ipad ibooks qui
s'offre un nouveau design et un nouveau
nom qui s'appelle maintenant apple books
tous que j'ai trouvé très intéressant
c'est l'application pour les voitures
car playes vous allez pouvoir choisir
votre gps votre navigateur
vous déploierez les google maps mais
aussi wise ça c'est intéressant ce que
quand on voit la popularité grandissante
de wade c'est top
des évolutions aussi du côté de l'option
ne pas déranger en pouvoir personnifié
aller plus loin au niveau des paramètres
les notifications aussi ont été revus ou
ayant des notifications les unes après
les autres sur votre accueil vous est
pouvoir des groupes de notification
notification dès sa notification
calendrier notification application
enfin pas mal de choses ça rend tout cas
tout ça beaucoup plus lisible est
beaucoup plus intéressante pour aller
directement à l'essentiel
à noter que je trouvais super
intéressant c'est les statistiques
d'utilisation de votre appareil ce
qu'ils appellent le screen times ça vous
permet de savoir combien de temps vous
avez passé sur une application
permettant de passer sur des réseaux
sociaux
regardez vos emails regarder des vidéos
à jouer un jeu fait de données
statistiques précises tout ça pour
apprendre un peu à limiter la
consommation et par un stand en excès
par exemple pouvait dire je vais rester
une heure maximum par jour sur instagram
est au bout d'une heure ça vous affiche
un message bon il est temps de bouger
pareil pour vos jeux vidéo et ça c'est
très intéressant plus pour les parents
se font une espèce de contrôle parental
de l'activité de votre enfant vous allez
contrôler son temps le jeu sont en
visionnage de vidéos sur youtube par
exemple ça va vous envoyer les
informations directement sur votre
iphone à vous donc pour coup il faut que
vous et votre enfant de cinq ans de
l'iphone obligatoire vous permet de
contrôler le temps d'utilisation de
votre enfant sur telle ou telle
application beaucoup c'est plutôt pas
mal côté b ça j'ai pas mal de nouveautés
nouveauté qu'est pas mal c'est le
minimum j c'est un petit peu une réponse
à samsung et crm moggi vous pouviez vous
personnalisés par des voies du visage
vraiment avoir un ami moggi qui vous
ressemble et là avec le mit moggi vie
siècle et déjà votre visage qu'on
connaît déjà la forme de votre visage
êtes vous maintenant à choisir votre
longueur de cheveux la couleur de vos
cheveux les lunettes
la pinte exacte de votre peau les yeux
la forme de vos yeux
nos oreilles mais globalement vous êtes
déjà ce qu avez vous fait ses petits
réglages et vous avez vraiment un alibi
qui vous ressemble c'est le mime oggi
c'est plutôt pas mal alors une fois de
plus le miniji par rapport aux modèles
samsung par rapport à samsung vous
pouvez l'ouvrir et utiliser les aérer
moggi un peu en dehors de vos sms et mms
là par contre avec eni bogies vous
restez vraiment cantonné apple iphone
ios en tout cas vous allez pas
l'utiliser dans les applications tierces
mais aussi de nouveaux effets sur
l'année sa rage pouvoir un petit peu d
effet ristic ouvert ainsi les petits
stickers sur vos images et lorsque vous
faites pas une nouveauté du côté de
votre jeunesse avec le watch os 5
l'accent est toujours mis sur la santé
sur la fitness avec l'application
activité qui permet de challenge and
amis vous avez différents types
d'activités qui sont présentes le yoga
la randonnée la course acteurs
extérieurs le vélo l'intérieur a gagné
pas mal de choses c'est plutôt pas mal
vous l accès à pas mal de statistiques
pour plus d'infos sur vous votre rythme
cardiaque
pas mal de choses et ça rend un peu le
tout assez intéressant surtout quand on
veut faire du sport un conte de pousser
un peu plus pour toujours savoir vont
demander pour dans sa progression petit
gadget que j'adorais c'est le talkie
walkie vous avez votre âge vous
choisissez avec qui vous voulez parler
et vous appuyez comme sur un taux qui
vous appuyez vous parler sa part la
personne directement sur sa montre vous
lâcher c'est elle qui parle comme un
talkie walkie comme ce que je faisais
quand j'étais gamin la fosse a toujours
super cool pour obligatoire il faut vous
et tous les deux une watch sinon ça
marche pas on ne possède pas lorsque
vous voulez avoir un aperçu d'une page
internet vous pouvez la voir directement
sur votre toit de cette fois ci c'est
pas mal ya la prise en charge du langage
internet html etc etc
si vous tapez pas mal sur une
application podcasts et il faut aussi
son apparition de nouveaux principes ont
été présentés avec un fond d'écran
complètement à sortir grâce au legs du
côté de l'apple tv ne mise à jour de tv
os sont directement ces dernières et ils
ont présenté tivi os cap car hdr cette
fois ci le son est aussi au rendez vous
avec du dolby atmos ce qui fait que vous
avez une image qui est vraiment top
en cas de cas avec de l'âge des airs et
là vous avez le son dolby et mots sont
vraiment une immersion toujours plus
c'est pas mal an pour la france en plus
vous y retrouver directement canal box
soit par l'apple tv
quatrième point non pas des moindres la
nouvelle mise à jour de mac os avec le
nouvel os qui s'appelle mojave alors moi
je lis mot jav mauges avait un en
français mais ça se prononce mojave donc
c'est mort avait et meaux avait plutôt
pas mal et notamment
le dark blue qui va vraiment concentré
sur la base sur leur travail
ça permet vraiment d'aller à l'essentiel
et je trouve ça plutôt pas mal fichu
en plus de ça vous avez votre fond
d'écran qui va évoluer en fonction des
heures de la journée lorsque vous
arrivez le soin besoin de fonds d'écran
qui arrivera sur le soir donc par
exemple lorsque vous est d'avoir une vue
sur une belle dune et quand la nuit
arrivera chez vous elle arrivera sur la
dune à l'appareil pour le matin c'est un
petit gadget mais c'est plutôt sympa
autres par catégorie par date
ce qui permettra d'avoir accès à un
bordel un peu plus organisés ou en tout
cas avoir un peu plus de visibilité
vous allez aussi pour profiter d'un
nouvel affichage on à l'affichage avec
les icônes en liste là vous allez avoir
le gall review vous allez pouvoir
naviguer comme dans une galerie et en
plus de ça à voir vos métadatas sur le
côté pour avoir des actions rapides
pouvoir éditer rapidement un document
pouvoir apposer une signature pouvoir
exporter un pdf voir ces quelques points
d'amélioration ça révolutionne pas nier
l'histoire ne s'est pas mal penser la
question d'écran était aussi améliorée
une autre option qui est pas mal c'est
ce qu'ils appellent le continuity caméra
ça vous permet lorsque vous allez
prendre une photo avec votre iphone de
l'utiliser directement sur votre mac
en gros votre action vous servir de
caméra sans fil pour envoyer des photos
directement sur votre mac pour toutes
les applications vous avez apple news
vous avez la bourse vous avez lenovo
qu'aux petites choses là combien
pourrait aussi dans votre mac os la
sécurité qui a vraiment été mise en
avant par apple la volonté de sécuriser
vos informations ne rien point qui m'a
un petit peu surpris il ce bouton de
partage
vous parlez de sécurité l'accès votre
caméra à votre micro on était vraiment
renforcé vous devrez vraiment validé
pour que ça puisse être activé via votre
navigateur
vraiment une mise en avant par apple de
la volonté de sécuriser vos données
personnelles ça c'est plutôt pas mal
le mac app store aussi s'offre un
nouveau design on peut poster des avis
plus facilement sur des applications
falloir pas mal de petites choses qui
sont un peu remise au goût du jour et à
la fin ils ont posé la question de ce
qu'on appelle le projet mardi pan l'idée
de dire est ce que on va unifier à ios
et mac os
ils ont dit très clairement non j'en ai
déjà parlé l'idée du projet d'un zip ans
pour moi c'était pas du tout de se dire
on va unifier à ios et mac os
mais l'idée de se dire on va pouvoir
faire des ponts des liens et pourquoi
pas avoir un code unique pour les deux
plateformes tout de suite c'est pas au
goût du jour mais on parle d'un côté on
a un langage qui est dédié à ios est un
langage qui est dédié à mac os est ce
qui explique et apple c'est qu'à une
petite partie du langage des os qui est
collée à mac os pour que les deux
puis ce communiqué très facilement avoir
dans le temps à quoi ça va ressembler du
point de vue des développeurs est ce
qu'ils vont réussir un petit peu plus à
unifier tous à ce fameux projet marie
pan puisqu'il est très clair c'est que
le fait d'avoir deux os similaires ça ne
verra jamais le jour
toutes ces mises à jour seront
disponibles dès l'automne à l'ordre au
final qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir tout
ça je dirais d'abord eu la venue des
signes un petit peu tiède petit petit
hélas d'un côté c'est plutôt bien on
voit qu'il ya des mises à jour qui sont
faites des choses qui sont assez sympa
les les minots ji c'est pas mal
rajouter de la sécurité au niveau de
safari au niveau de mac os ça aussi
c'est important
le dolby et mot sur l'apple tv c'est top
le dark mode sûrement rabé bien talkie
walkie sur votre show est pas mal c'est
du gadget mais c'est rigolo
la réalité augmentée qui mise en avance
aussi bien il ya pas mal de petites
choses qui mis bout à bout sont sympas
mais sur sept qui note de présentation
du tableau des meneurs ici il n'y a pas
eu un truc où tu dis waouh voilà l'effet
waouh il est pas là on a l'impression
qu'apple va chercher à asseoir ses os à
les rendre plus stable plus solide plus
sérieux plus de sécurité
quelque chose qui va rassurer le
consommateur qui va rassurer aussi
probablement les actionnaires mais bon
c'est pas sur cette keynote qui est des
choses un petit peu fofolle vont
résilier roi où ça si c'est la
révolution il ya un nouveau truc qui
arrive c'est pas le cas
là le ton était donné du côté uniquement
développeurs à voir maintenant ce qui va
se passer au mois de septembre
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez ce
que vous êtes satisfait ce que vous êtes
déçu oui non est ce que vous êtes
content voilà vous marquez tout ça et on
en parle ensemble
rassurez vous on reste connectés on va
reparler très prochainement d'apple
on va essayer de bord un petit peu ce
qui va se profiler maintenant va y avoir
forcément tous les analystes qui vont
bosser là dessus et croyez-moi des infos
il va y en avoir plein qui vont
commencer à fêter donc on va se
connecter
merci en tout cas à vous d'avoir gagné
cette vidéo là il est rare je les ai dit
et maintenant elle une couche et il est
22h 29
donc voilà soyez ça nous on passe il ya
très bientôt tonnes
[Musique]